hello everyone
how's everybody doing
i hope you're doing fine forgot to turn
uh something off here
i hope you can hear me well you can see
me well
today we have the question live question
and answer session
and i'm going to do a review of the
month at the end of the uh session here
uh i'm gonna try to see if people ask
some
rational questions i'm gonna try to
answer them or some topics that are of
interest to everyone
anyways let me start with the review of
the month month of january 2022 hey 2022
we've been 2 000 years around
since
the days of jesus christ
congratulations
humanity
okay anyways uh what we had uh lately at
least since this last time
uh a lot of moonies
who are the moonies well the moonies are
people who don't believe that humans
ever stepped on the moon
and here we have them those are the
moonies you know they say no no it's
impossible
we couldn't have gone to the moon
and they come up with all these
different theories of why man could not
have stepped on the moon
among them especially you know are the
flat earthers
and the reason for that is very clear
you know
if uh if we went to the moon
or even far out from the earth somewhere
right
and we could take a picture of the earth
from afar
well obviously uh
you know the pictures don't lie
[Laughter]
you know it shows you that the earth is
roundish it's spherical
and so yeah the flat earthers among
are the primary people who deny that
humans went out into space let alone to
the moon okay so they're the first
people who object to that they say uh
not even satellites went out there
because you know you can send a a probe
out there and automatically have the
probe take a picture of the earth that
hasn't happened either because if that
happens again their
their whole theory their whole
hypothesis their whole
uh proposal that earth is flat goes down
to drain
so yeah they're the first deniers but
there are a lot of people who are not
flat earthers who deny that we went to
the moon as well
and they say prove it to us bill
prove that humans went to the moon
and i can prove to you that humans did
not go to the moon can you prove
otherwise
so that's where we have to start today
we have to start on
you know uh proving
okay so let's let's begin by proving
okay and what we do in order to prove
is to address this issue because it's so
ingrained in the minds of people
is uh
we do one thing and one thing only we
have to attack or we have to analyze
the scientific method
especially the mathematical physics
method
what we call mathematics
okay
and so here i can give you an outline of
what the mathematical
physics method is all about okay and
this is where they got all these ideas
of proof bill prove that we went to the
moon okay
and these are the 10 deadly sins of
mathematical physics okay we have truth
belief
prediction you know they like to do
predictions in mathematical physics they
think it's a an integral part of the
scientific method the scientific method
that they inherited from the fourth cent
17th century for 400 years now and the
one they continue to vouch for okay this
is what they learn in school and they
just regurgitate they say yeah we do
predictions okay and so
they do an experiment to
prove their hunches or to test their
hunches they do a measurement a
calculation comes out with an equation
they call this evidence
they introduce the evidence in court of
law as proof
once uh it's presented we call that
knowledge because now it's converted
into knowledge and knowledge becomes
fact and everybody simply
blesses it and calls it truth from then
on
okay
so this is how uh the so-called
scientific method of mathematical
physics progresses
okay
and so what's the issue
the issue is uh you say bill can you
prove that we went to the moon
and the answer is no i can't
can you prove that napoleon
existed and went to waterloo
uh no i can't
can you prove that caesar went to
england you know 2 000 years ago
no i can't i can't prove to you
that any of that ever happened that
napoleon existed that caesar existed
louis the 14th and france existed i
cannot
prove any of that
so uh
i can't use that at all
i can't use that as a hypothesis i can't
say let us assume that napoleon went to
waterloo
i cannot do that
because you're saying that i can't prove
it so uh
i can't even make the assumption
you know jfk never happened uh
9 11 never happened nothing ever
happened
the nuclear bombs over hiroshima and
nagasaki that never happened
so so the question is
is that what science is about we simply
say that well all that's history and
history is a lie
written by the victors and they all lie
because they're all politicians or who
know they have some kind of interest
and so none of that ever happened i will
not accept
well hopefully the scientific method
doesn't work that way you know we have
problems with the scientific method
working like that no i cannot prove to
you that napoleon existed
okay so if i'm gonna tell a theory of
why he went to
waterloo
you know what drove him to go out there
something called philosophy history
right
uh i'm not allowed to do that because
you know i cannot prove
even that napoleon was ever there
what am i supposed to do bring a film of
napoleon going to waterloo and say uh
napoleon would you would you mind if i
film you so that i can show these
nuts
in the 21st century that you went to
waterloo what am i supposed to do
no you can't prove
those kinds of things okay and so i
cannot bring to you again
uh neil armstrong and buzz aldrin going
to the moon in 1969 i cannot bring to
you i can show you a movie and you say
that was made in hollywood
i don't even think that neil armstrong
existed
and so i'm done you know i i cannot
prove to you that neil armstrong was a
human being that was alive in 1969 and i
cannot prove to you that he went to the
moon and walked on the moon i cannot do
that in real time i mean i can show you
a movie that's about the best i can do
and you can say well that's fake made in
hollywood and i'm done you know i i
cannot go beyond that
does that mean we don't accept any of
that we cannot even discuss the issue
because it never happened
is that the way science works
now in science we don't prove okay and
this notion of proof
is what's at issue
what has happened in uh at least in the
last 400 years really
further than that is that the
mathematicians the mathematical
physicists
introduce this notion
of or reinforce the notion that already
was there you know from the days of the
greeks
they reinforced this notion that uh
science is like you know
a trial
you know you get a trial uh someone is
being accused of murder or of raping or
whatever
some crime
and
so the person is brought there and the
prosecutor has to convince the jury
not in every country but at least in
some countries you have like 12 jurors
in there and the prosecutor structure
is going to try to do what he's going to
try to persuade and convince them
that his theory
his version of the facts
is correct
it's true
and it's more than that i want you to
not only say well yeah
it's a nice theory no no no no you have
to vote for that theory
as a juror
you must swear you say i vote for that
theory
and if 12 of them
vote for the theory
it becomes a fact
now it's a fact you're a criminal you're
guilty you go to prison you get executed
whatever
so it's not just it has consequences
it's not just that the guy says well you
know do you like my theory yeah it's a
nice theory no no no it goes beyond that
and so this is the way these people
treat all this stuff and they say look
we're gonna prove to you
through evidence
through persuasion
through whatever means through through
uh experiments
we're going to prove to you that this is
the way the universe works
that's the notion of science that we
have today
and so here you see
also a little uh synopsis of what the
mathematicians think
science is about
and what people
out there think science is about because
the mathematicians told them this
okay uh
you know the the issue is persuading
convincing converting and recruiting you
you know so you gawk and you say oh well
the scientists or the mathematicians all
these phds they they convinced me
that uh
something like this happened like you
know uh
gravity is warped space or that a
particle can be at two places at once
it hurts your your intelligence
but you say well what can i do i mean if
it's all these
intellectuals all these people who are
degreed who studied 10 15 years at a
university if they say it's true and
they all believe in it
well you know who am i
little puny me
to to counteract these people
no i have to believe that what these
people are saying is true because you
know they fed it to me they did all
these experiments
who am i to judge them
okay so this is where the problem is
people believe that science is about
persuading about recruiting
and how do you recruit how do you
persuade well you have to convince
people that what you're saying is the
truth
how do you convince people that you are
saying the truth you prove it to them
and so how do you convince people that
humans went
on the moon
well you prove it to them
so how do you prove it to them
well the way you prove it to them you
show them a movie
and they say i'm still not convinced
uh i don't think that happened i think
that was all filmed in hollywood or you
know in houston or wherever miami
never happened
okay so we have a problem because maybe
if i can't prove it to you it means it's
not part of science it's not part of the
scientific method
i can't use it again as an assumption
is that what we're talking about here
okay and so um here's another
version of that you know this is what uh
mathematical physics does
and they talk been talking about proof
since the days of the greek
and what are we talking about here well
we're seeing that you know
mathematicians might say a mathematician
might say to you say look a
circumference is three times you know
uh the diameter
of any circle
okay and uh so what is that that's a
tautology
certainly he hasn't explained anything
and what's on one side of the equal sign
is equal to the other side
that looks like a tautology
i mean i i don't think uh we've
explained anything with this
you know if you make a circle for sure
that diameter i mean perfect circle that
diameter is going to be you know
one-third of that
circumference
great
and so we found this relation we call it
a
and so i say to you i'm going to prove
to you that that is the case
and so the word proof
ended up entering the uh
lexicon of the mathematicians they prove
things
they say you can trust math because
that's
you know you can put your hand in the
fire for that for an equation
yeah because it's a tautology that's why
you put your money into fire for that
that's why you can trust it
does that mean we have gained the
understanding
and people say well we didn't gain
understanding but we gained knowledge
you gain knowledge what do you mean by
knowledge
and now we get into the uh the the
language that you're using now what do
we mean by these words
okay so
and we'll move on here a little bit
because we'll get there in a second
anyways here's uh the difference between
mathematical physics
and science okay we gotta distinguish
between these two currents science is
one thing mathematical physics is
something else that has nothing at all
whatsoever to do with physics or with
science
supposedly a branch of physics okay here
it is okay mathematical physics what are
they concerned with well they they have
two things equations and irrational
explanations not a single one
you know not a single theory
of mathematical physics is rational and
i'm talking about anything related to
invisible and intangible mechanisms
invisible and intangible mediators
like for gravity and magnetism for
example right
so what is a hypothesis under these
people well they think a hypothesis is a
half truth
or an untrue theory it's half true
theory right it's not yet proven you got
a hunch that's all you got okay
what's a theory well it's a little truer
theory because they ran an experiment
and they proved the hypothesis to some
degree or some people believe in it and
some people are still not convinced
and when does it become a fact well it
becomes a fact when you prove it that
means that all mathematicians raise
their hands and vote for it and say
we like it
it has now become a fact because we all
believe in it we all believe in the flat
earth
so we all raise our hands and now we if
the flat earth has become truth
fact okay that's the way it is
but uh what is a theory under
mathematical physics well it's just a
mathematical description that's all it
is
the the mathematical physicists believe
that a description you know an equation
that's a theory
well that's not the case in science okay
in science
we look for rational explanations we
don't care what your equation says
we want to make sure that when you come
to the conference you give us a rational
explanation of a mechanism especially
for invisible intangible
mediators mechanisms that's the issue
and so in order to give you a
uh rational explanation we need to have
what is known as a hypothesis which is
not a half-truth or a half-baked theory
now it's the objects the definitions and
the statement of the facts that you need
to present in order for people to follow
your train of thought that's what a
hypothesis is the hypothesis only is
your first
it's the first step of the scientific
method you have to present what objects
are going to be performing were are
going to be acting in your theory what
are your definitions
you know i mean do you have consistent
definitions
or do you have definitions that
contradict each other or many
definitions for the same word that you
use throughout your your uh
exposition in other words you define one
thing and then you use it in a different
way throughout your dissertation
and then the statement of the facts is
not the facts
only mother nature father universe the
devil god one of those guys they know
the facts they have it in their cabinet
they know exactly what happened we
humans we petty humans we do not have an
idea of what
happened all we can do is have the
prosecutor tell us
his version
of the facts we call that the statement
of the facts
theory theory is an explanation and
hopefully it follows from those
uh assumptions known as hypothesis
okay
they follow from those they you have to
have those objects no definition those
statement of the facts the explanation
the theory follows from those uh
those assumptions those two positions
and then you have the conclusions which
are just the interpretations particular
interpretations you know different
people might have different
interpretations for
the same assumptions and fields
so we have a difference between
mathematical
physics
physics with quotation there
and genuine physics science okay there's
difference
so uh when we get to the moonies all
these people you know they come up with
all these weird notions
and they say i can prove to you or i can
disprove to you or whatever no again we
don't prove in uh in science so
if if you're using the word proof in any
way shape or form if you're using the
word knowledge in any way shape or form
you have not yet understood the
scientific method
okay it's just as simple as that and so
let's move on here let's find out what
some of these people questioned or asked
or made comments about regarding the
moon right okay
and one fellow says builders this info
agent
for outer space in globe earth
uh both of which are really demonstrably
not true
true
truth uh truth is in the eye of the
beholder
again you can see how they introduce
these these uh words
the truth prove
uh i know
they know they know for a fact okay
there is overwhelming evidence evidence
that we did not land on the moon
okay uh the moon the evidence i see is a
little movie there where you see uh
armstrong and aldrin go on the surface
of the moon
uh i mean that looks like evidence
doesn't i could introduce that in a
trial
and these people say oh that's fake
that happened in hollywood in houston
okay
what can i say you are fake truther okay
so you can see how these people are very
fanatic about proving and truthing
and a lot of this comes from politics
has very little to do with science
people have political
um
issues
they hate the politicians they hate the
rich people who
you know are out there they say all
these people have power and i have no
power and i hate them because all
they're doing is feeding me baloney
and so they don't believe anything that
comes
out of the you know the top
and all i can tell you is you know you
got to choose your conspiracy theories
carefully you got to do a little
research i mean if you're going to be so
fanatic about it you say oh this never
happened make sure you read up on it
don't just say stuff because otherwise
you're going to come out across
as an ignorant fool
and it's a ignoramus
so
do a little bit of research and
you know the first thing you have to do
as a researcher is
criticize your own theories attack
what you believe
if you can do that it's very hard to do
that but if you can do that if you can
attack that guy in the mirror
you know his ideas
then at least you have a stronger case
you can say okay i've attacked it from
every angle
and i can defend now every argument
that's the issue if you can get to that
point then uh you're a smart man okay
okay another fella says says uh flag
waving shadows in general and jumping
gravity is worth half
there's a lot of footage of weird
anti-gravity movements
if you answer all of them in a rational
scientific way as you like
i will come to visit you in frankfurt
and offer you a five liter beer okay i
hope so you know i i hope you you you
keep your promise right your bet okay
i i need a five liter b i can do that i
can work with that you know i'd rather
have that and not a nobel prize you know
yeah i can do something with that i
can't do anything with a metal you know
okay so here's the the answers areas of
cosmic proportions the stars in the
background flag wave gravity jumps
shadows cast by astronaut you can
criticize anything you want the problem
is that the more stuff you put in there
the least likely you are going to
prevail with your notion that uh you
know that this never happened that the
moon landings never happened because
what you're saying is that the people in
um in nasa
or hollywood or whoever the director of
the movie that they showed throughout
the 60s right
that they were they made so many errors
you know these guys didn't know anything
about anything i mean they were such
idiots that you know they they forgot to
put stars in the background oh that's
stupid and they they allowed the you
know the wave to the flag to wave
and uh
and then you know uh
the jumping of the astronauts on the
moon that was wrong too
you know it's again it's the case of the
roman gladiator who uh who in the course
of the movie he's wearing a rolex watch
and you say well
that's kind of strange that that doesn't
seem right
you know and if you make an error like
that as a director you know you're fired
you can't have this guy you know go in
there with his sword and uh you know
fight another guy and have a you know a
rolex watch on on his wrist
and and when you have too many of those
i mean you could have missed one
something that happened you know maybe a
car in the distance while the gladiators
were fighting well
uh take 45
got to change that
scene you know you got to take that
scene out and you would think that you
know the people in nasa
and or hollywood whoever made these
1960s movies 70s and etc movies
of men going to the moon and going into
outer space they would have made so many
errors
so the more errors you find
the less likely your theory is so try to
find less fewer errors okay
because i don't think they would have
made so many errors when you find so
many errors
something is wrong with
you it's something that you don't
understand about physics and about
science okay so it shows more on you
than on on the movie that you're you've
got in front of you
okay and another fella says but what if
they are giving us the errors in the
films to clean up their guilt
oh
this is a new point of view okay kind of
we gave them hints
that should have made the useless uh
uh eaters understand it but they didn't
so it's on them to be deceived
you deserve to be deceived because
you're an ignoramus and they can get
away with all this stuff and you don't
understand it see
and so yeah i mean how how far are
people going to take this thing
i think these people are overthinking
i mean way overthinking this thing they
look for ways of
throwing down
you know that humans went to the moon
and they said well they couldn't have
gone to the moon because he maybe maybe
the powers that be
they made those errors on purpose
and if you couldn't figure that out well
you're obviously a dummy
so they have all kinds of arguments you
know it's just unbelievable i love all
the arguments these people come up with
okay
okay here's another vow he says what the
astronauts have cooked in the lamb on
the moon in direct sun radiation you
know you have all this radiation
just hitting you
you know
here on earth we're protected by the
atmosphere but out there in space
there's nothing there except your space
suit okay so they're saying you would be
zapped
okay
and a bunch of car batteries would not
have had enough power to cool the air
inside without being able to pump the
air outside the hot air outside
so they have all these reasoning for why
the moon never happened because you know
none of the astronauts would have
survived it's either radiation or you
know the jumping or the shadows or the
stars in the background something went
wrong
couldn't have been we can't make it to
the moon we don't have the
intelligence of technology or never had
it or never had it in the 60s and now
maybe we do but we haven't gone to the
moon and that also proves that we didn't
in the 60s because why don't they go to
the moon
they should have gone to the moon again
right we should have gone to the moon
every year for the next
million years
and my answer is
why would anyone go to the moon
why what is there in the moon that you
want
you know
is there something there on the moon
that you think is valuable that we could
bring to earth
and even in mining think of mining you
know i mean if we brought it from the
moon it'd be a little expensive
i mean if we had no such things on earth
no metals of some kind and we can find
it on the moon maybe uranium or
something for example
right
um
so we bring it from from the moon
because there is no more uranium on
earth we can understand that
but as long as we have uranium on earth
uh why would we go to the moon to mine
it and bring it here when it costs
a lot more
just to do that
okay so it's a
question of uh you know are you going to
empty the treasure
of the world just to get some uranium
here on earth
are we going to bring potatoes from the
moon you know i mean
what would we go to the moon for
and yes we did and people say well we
went to the moon several times yes we
did we went to the moon for a given
reason and that was to do some
experiments
on the moon
uh some of them having to do with
vacuum
right you can perform the experiment in
a vacuum more or less you know 10 to 11
minus 11 torr maybe minus 12 torr
thereabouts
and you can perform these experiments on
the moon
without having to have a vacuum chamber
here on earth some experiments you do
want to do on the moon in a natural
environment not have to have an
artificial environment
you know i mean you know we had to pump
down our chambers at amd advanced micro
devices when we built chips
and it takes several hours we didn't
pump it down below minus seven because
seven minus seven door because we did
not really need that kind of vacuum we
could live with a five to the minus
seven torr range
so uh you know that's what we pumped it
down to and it took a long time until
the machine was ready to put wafers in
there okay to to get chips out of there
and you know when you go to the moon you
have a natural environment and all you
have to do is just put your equipment
there
and some of the equipment that they put
in there among others you know was the
lunar ranging
experiment where you can gauge
the distance of the earth to the moon
with the laser from the earth
so they put the equipment there they
came back now they can focus the laser
on the lunar ranging on this retro
reflector and you can tell whether the
moon is getting closer or farther away
from earth one
and more important than that which is
what i say that experiment is is really
awesome in that sense that you can tell
something about the nature of light
because that laser shines directly
to the laser not where the laser is
going to be in
you know one kilometer because the earth
moves approximately one kilometer per
second
around the earth
um light takes approximately three
hundred thousand but it takes
approximately um
three hundred thousand kilometers
to travel in one second
the moon is a little farther away just
rounding off one second to get to the
moon and round trip two seconds right
three hundred six hundred thousand
really more like eight hundred thousand
but the issue is
if if you don't have to shoot
the laser to where the moon is going to
be in one kilometer which is where the
moon is going to be by the time the
photons get there and come back
really two kilometers really because the
earth also moves etc and so the issue is
you know you can tell something about
the nature of light because that means
that
light in that sense is
instantaneous
meaning not instantaneous in the sense
that the signal travels along
you know from one place to another
instantaneously but in the sense that
you know if you have a rope all it has
to do is troll in place
and it's the signal that takes 300 000
or you know
travels 300 000 kilometers in one second
but the rope tools in place and it's
already tied from one atom to another
from the laser
to the retro reflector they're already
tied the moon can go anywhere at once it
doesn't matter that atom is going to be
connected to the atom on the moon
and that's instantaneous because they're
connected permanently
and the only thing we've got along that
rope is just a torsion 300 000
kilometers per second which is the
signal prop of the propagation of the
torsion
okay so
the retro reflector at least told us
that but
we did a lot of experiments on the moon
that's why they had to make several
trips they said why don't we do this
experiment what would you do this other
one and meanwhile they they develop
capsules they develop spacesuits
they develop certain technology that was
useful
and once they did all that they said
well do we have any more experiments to
do on the moon and they said no we're
done we did almost everything we could
think of maybe tomorrow they think of
something else fine but right now you
know
after they did the the last trip to the
moon they said we're done we don't need
uh to go to the moon anymore
they they brought rocks from the moon
they scar scar the area you know they
went through through the moon through
wherever they went they saw the back
side of the moon great and once we did
all that we went came back home we said
we don't have to go to the moon ever
again
what are we going to go to the moon for
put a station there
and feed the asteroids from earth every
month every two months whatever
send air out there send water out there
setting food out there
there is no reason to go to the moon
ever again
okay
i hope that
falls into the heads of some moonies
okay another foul says
he says i don't believe i know
that the u.s landing with humans has
never happened
and it reminds me of the three stooges
mo says do you think you can fix it and
larry says uh i don't think
i know
mo says i don't think you know either
and this guy said i don't believe i know
yeah i don't believe you know either
okay yeah
[Music]
some of these people crack me up okay so
this is the issue belief is equal to
knowledge so when you say you believe
you're saying yet you know when you say
that you know you say that you believe
knowledge is according to mr plato
justified true belief in no one since
the days of plato has ever improved on
that definition so anyone who says i
know all you're saying is that you
believe
because it means that uh you're not
going to change your knowledge you're
not going to change your way of thinking
okay it means you believe and no matter
what i do you know your stuff and i
can't change your way of thinking in any
way
and so belief and knowledge are exactly
synonyms that's why we don't use either
belief or knowledge in science okay
and uh
so here yeah here you have uh neil
armstrong and buzz aldrin the first two
guys to go to the moon
uh to step on the moon okay and so uh
you know some people say this never
happened okay so uh this was what filmed
in uh hollywood
okay uh are the shadows right i hope
they're right because otherwise you know
i'm gonna get a lot of flack
yeah
you know i mean what can i tell you uh
am i supposed to take you back to the
days
in which uh
to 69 and say look
uh let me take you back in time you know
go through uh
time travel and take you there and say
see it it did happen
is that the way i'm supposed to prove it
to you
and please tell me how i can prove it to
you and i'll i'll go out of my way to
prove it to you to convince you to
persuade you to recruit you into the
religion of moon landing
okay what am i supposed to do you tell
me okay how am i supposed to prove to
you
now you can have arguments against to
say look i have a theory that uh this
could have failed or whatever you know
you can you can come up with that
and it's just a theory okay that's all
it is theories we don't prove we don't
prove theories in science all we do is
explain them so that you understand them
okay i understood your argument
let me munch on it crunch it and i'll
sleep on it and i'll tell you tomorrow
and tomorrow all i can do is tell you my
opinion that's the best i can do i
cannot tell you i've proven you wrong
or you proved
yourself right or you proved to me that
you were right i can't do that i can't
do either one of those i can only say i
understood your theory i understood your
your objection
and i much done it and later on i can
say i believed it or i did not believe
it and again that's only my personal
opinion has nothing to do with everybody
the eight billion people out there
who do not agree with you
okay
that makes just two of us you and me who
now believe in your theory okay that's
all it is
okay uh
many ancient uh
books speak of humans who left the earth
with alien ships
[Laughter]
yeah
i guess
there's a lot of those mythology you
know they also all these people also
talked about spirits and angels and with
jesus christ going up to heaven coming
back and staying three days with us and
then going back you know uh
are we supposed to believe all this
stuff uh noah's ark had two of each kind
even two dinosaurs and
two
pterosaurs
uh you know are we supposed to believe
all this stuff just because it's in the
ancient books
some people have this notion that the
ancients had knowledge that we lost over
time that they knew more than we do
my poor god yeah this is what some
people believe okay a lot of this comes
when uh
people who make money off of books
here's one guy okay his name was eric
von daniken a lot of people know him and
he wrote chariots of the gods made a lot
of money selling that book
and this fella just came out there and
said you know uh the ancients
uh received the visits of the et's
of the klingons or the martians or
whoever and we know this for a fact
because you know they could have built
the pyramids
uh either in egypt or in the mayan
pyramids or whatever you know so this
guy went out there looking for what for
evidence
and what did he do he persuaded he tried
to convince you he tried to convert you
try to recruit you
that's that's what he was all about and
since people believe that that's what
science is about you know a lot of
people thought that this guy was selling
science saying hey you know he's a
scientist because he came up with this
theory
that the et's
came to
govern us and then they left for some
reason and they didn't leave any ray gun
you know unfortunately we could have
seen the reagan say oh in the pyramid
you know in a tomb of uh two-time common
founder ray got injured
obviously
klingons were here you know they didn't
leave anything not a single bullet not a
gun not a uh
spaceship not a piece of
a chunk of you know some alloy that we
don't have today you know none of that
they left none of that they just left us
pyramids rocks
one on top of the other
yeah
and a lot of people believe in this
stuff because they say well you know uh
the the martians came they visited us
then they went back why did they go back
why don't they come again now we're
intelligent enough to understand them
see our forefathers you know they didn't
understand any of that
they didn't they never saw anything
flying in the air as a flying saucer
you know we saw airplanes and you know
for those who believe in rockets that go
into space rockets right
and so you know we can show these things
and we understand them we we've seen
them we've got experience with them so
if the et's come
and visit us now
and um
and you know bring some flying saucer
we're going to be a little more
in tune with what they're you know what
they uh have there because we say well
we have some experience with that we
know we can fly through the air our
ancients you know forefathers they had
no idea they never saw anything fly
through the air not even a balloon
you know so
bad timing for the for the ets to come
you know two thousand three thousand
four thousand years ago they should have
come now
and vice versa you know all these people
talk about myths about stories of people
who went into outer space or to heaven
or to hell you know all the spirits
flying around
my god and people say yeah the ancients
knew more than we did
[Laughter]
they swallow all this stuff they love it
it's it's nice for bedtime stories no
problem there i like to tell them when
my kids were little i used to tell them
bedtime stories like that in fact i read
a lot of them from the bible
and they loved them you know they went
to sleep and they loved them but uh to
think that they were real all these
stories
for people grown-ups to believe this
stuff today it's unbelievable
okay another foul says you actually
gobbling up moronic fairy tale space
concepts example a vacuum space with
spinning stone balls
yeah you know the
moon goes around the earth saying are
you kidding me
and then again the flat earthers you
know they have that the moon and the sun
even going around
the flat earth so i don't know what this
person was talking about i mean what
what theory does he have is it it has
me you know uh
at the edge of my seat you know i'm
wondering
if if uh these uh balls these stone
balls if they don't orbit they don't go
around
flat earthers talk about the same thing
you know the sun and the moon go around
the earth up above your flat earth and
sun in the moon going around
and so you know uh
i don't know what to tell i don't know
what this guy is
proposing in the alternative be nice to
know
anyways uh
uh he says
people in flexible suits magically
withstanding high ultra high vacuum
uh
landing on a magically interlockedly uh
rotating moon on the dark side
yeah well you know here you have
what i showed the other day that yeah we
have this space environment complex it's
a testing center in ohio
and what they do is they have this big
chamber and they put the astronauts in
there and what they do they pump it down
to about minus six tours okay
level takes about eight hours
and uh yeah minus six doesn't match the
uh ultra high vacuum of the moon which
is minus 11 torr okay
solar wind is a little higher apparently
uh more or less the same
but um you know minus six is far away
from that
and yet you know uh yes that's that's
what uh we do we don't have to test them
at minus 11 torr at ultra high vacuum
anything beyond -6 even beyond -5 will
kill you if you don't have any kind of
protection okay so yeah you do have to
be suited up and the suits are made in
such a way that you can withstand
you know the lack of back the lack of
pressure the the vacuum out there and
here on the left you see the uh
people who go underwater
uh does that never did that ever happen
i mean we have these suits to go under
water and their pressurized suits in
such a way that
the pressure underwater will not crunch
you will not turn you into a little uh
you know um
crunched uh
beer pan
so they have these suits that protect
you against the pressure down at the
bottom of the sea
and people don't believe in this either
i mean this is something that you can
prove here on earth you don't have to go
out into outer space
so why don't you think that if this is
true assuming that you accept that why
don't you think that's also true
or possibly true that a human with a
special type of suit that has some
protection from the inside
can go into outer space and have this
protection uh within his suit
i mean uh
we're not talking about really such high
level um technology here okay we're not
talking something that's inconceivable
but these people deny it completely off
the bat they say i don't believe in that
and uh so i don't know what to tell you
you know i mean yeah
you got to kill your ignorance that's
all you can do
and here we have a the first man who
went into outer space i mean walked
in space okay he was uh leonov
and um
the uh says fellow cells there the
spacecraft as the vehicles are
pressurized at the space suit as the
vehicles are pressurized the first walk
uh in the black sky was by leona in 65
in a pressurized suit which ballooned
when it uh posted the vacuum
uh actually not true okay so he
stated it wrong so let me clarify that
he was in outer space gradually
gradually he had a problem with his suit
where you know it was inflating so it's
not like he went out there and said
whoop and you know went back in now now
he went out there he was there for a
couple minutes
and his suit began to balloon so he he
realized either it had a leak or from
the inside whatever
material he had in there that was
protecting him
uh was not working the way it was
supposed to what was the problem it
ballooned a little bit
enough for him not to be able to make it
through that little hole
back into the capsule
and so what happened was
he he he he was uh
playing with his life right there he
realized that and he started
depressurizing his suit so that it would
constrict a little bit so he could get
through the hole
but he couldn't
do it uh in such a way
that he was exposed to the vacuum and he
would die before he could get in
so he had to find the right place
and you know that that this thing
contracted sufficiently
uh for him to get through the hole
and so he lost about half the
pressure in there or the lack of
pressure right uh in there uh so that he
could get him through the hole so his
suit shrunk enough for him to fit
through the hole
okay so he had that problem but uh yeah
this was in 1965
by 1969 when these guys went out there
which was one of the things they had to
obviously test before they sent a human
out there
the suits were improved significantly
okay and they had four years in which
they developed suits in fact by 1967 two
years later they had suits that were
already primed so that these people
could go out into space
you know so the next space walk was not
as dangerous as was leonov's okay
okay uh
a couple people uh
clarified something when paul says the
moon orbits the earth every once every
27 days it also takes approximately 27
days for the moon to rotate once on its
axis
father corrects something says the moon
doesn't orbit around the earth it's in a
sinusoidal path simultaneously entitled
life
uh what's the issue here the issue is
that the moon always shows the same face
to the earth more or less there's an
eight-degree wobble
okay of the moon so that we can see
eight degrees more of one side sometimes
and eight degrees more of another side
but essentially we always see the same
face of the moon plus those
you know that those eight degrees on
each side so the moon kind of wobbles as
it goes around the earth but essentially
is in what is known as a synchronous
orbit
okay
so uh what is an orbit well we say an
orb is just going around
uh what is the spin
does the moon spin on its axis like
shown right there at the bottom the
answer is no
the moon doesn't spin
okay so people
this is a game of words at some point
because people say well it doesn't orbit
and it does spin
because the spin is exactly equal to one
revolution of the orbit etc and they get
tangled in all this
uh semantics that's what it amounts to
so
let's just state it plainly the moon
doesn't spin like a top on its axis
on a given
in a couple locations that it has you
know with respect to the earth it
doesn't spin on its axis it rotates
around the earth with one face paint
facing always to the earth wobbling a
little bit back and forth that's it
that's why we don't see the other side
of the moon ever unless you go to the
moon and with some device vehicle or
maybe a human and take a picture of the
moon from the other side which they've
done
and so the issue is the following
this shows once again if the moon
doesn't leave the earth
and it always faces the earth more or
less you know wobbling back and forth
it means that
the reason the moon doesn't fly out of
the solar system it's because somehow
it's attached to the earth what you're
staring at there
is when a boy twirls uh you know
a ball around his head
that's what you're seeing there
just plain and simple it's straight
forward
okay now you say i don't see a string
yeah you can't see the mediator of
gravity but what you're staring at there
is the earth swinging the earth
the moon around itself okay
i always show it here
this is what you're seeing
that's exactly what you're seeing
okay
and so you say well i don't see
the uh
the string
the connection between the earth and the
moon or between the earth and the sun
because you can see the earth is also
bound to the sun in the same way yeah
you don't see the mediators of gravity
that doesn't mean there is no physical
mediator there because if you deny
that there is a physical mediator
between the earth and the moon between
the earth and the sun
then you're you're introducing black
magic
you're saying that the earth goes around
the sun there's no physical entity that
binds us to the sun
maybe angels
spirits
there's nothing there but the earth
doesn't fly away out of the solar system
and the moon doesn't fly away out of the
solar system doesn't leave the earth
why why does it continue rolling
perpetually around the earth
you have to answer them you got to give
me the mechanism
what are you going to say that uh
einstein is right that we have warped
space warp space time four dimensional
unimaginable unimaginable space time is
that what what this is all about
well space-time is a concept you can't
say this a concept stops
a celestial object a thing
where we're standing on top of this
earth right
you can't say that concept
stops the earth from flying out of the
solar system or the moon from flying out
of the solar system
that's like saying love
stops
uh the earth from flying out of the
solar system what do you mean love stops
the earth comes against the skin of the
earth
so clearly there's a problem when people
say well space-time does this
and that the earth is rolling around
space-time and it's a depression like a
roulette a little ball around the
roulette and that's why the earth
doesn't fly out
no you got a problem there because
first of all you cannot do this
with a three-object system as you're
seeing there you can do it with two
objects you can say well yeah here
here's the ball here in my hand we're
going to say the the hand is the sun the
earth is the ball okay
and
you know that i can show you
with two objects
and you can do the same thing with uh
relativity you can say the sun weighs
down space-time
and the earth has no other choice but to
roll around space-time
so far so good
okay let's let's concede let's accept
how about the moon now let's introduce a
third object okay
well you can say that in in our case you
can say that yeah it's a
an epicycle you know the
uh
sun moves the earth around
and the earth now my hand is the earth
moves the moon around
we can see those two
objects being spun around you know like
using that mechanism
you can't do that with space time
because if you if
if uh the moon if the sun warps
space-time
and earth
moves around the sun
if earth warps space-time locally to
have the moon go around
you know the earth well i'm sure the
warping
caused by the sun will affect that
motion
you cannot have these two warpings of
space-time one by the sun one by the
earth and have the moon have a circular
more or less circular slightly
elliptical orbit around the earth
okay so that's the problem you can't do
this the the
the uh
relativistic mechanism of space time you
can't do with a free object system
especially when you include that uranus
swings over and around its head
you know the moon goes over towards the
sun and you have
pluto in sharon you know it's like a
bullseye pattern as seen from the sun
so all these here's the sun warping
space time all the way to
the end of the solar system warps it
down in the same way for everybody but
all these planets
warp their locally their moons
in or their space times in a different
way one wipes it downwards the other one
sideways the other one you know to the
other side you can't have that
they should all be going in the same
direction that's not the case so this
space-time nonsense you cannot introduce
uh you cannot explain a three-body
system you can only explain the two body
system with it
okay so that's the issue
okay uh and uh final issue here with
respect to the moon why do you ask
yourself the problem of the supply of a
base uh luna or even a martian you know
lunar based and farsi and base okay
doesn't it happen constantly every day
every hour minute according to the
furnishing of a metropolis or a military
base in the
desert or a ship or a platform in the
middle of the sea
guy says uh you know
we can supply the moon just like or we
can supply mars we can supply pluto why
is this such a big issue with you
again uh people these people don't think
that they don't seem to have a brain i
don't know i don't know what's going on
i mean here we're talking about here's
the average distance between mars
and
earth uh typically the shortest this is
like 35
million kilometers uh
farthest this i think is around 440
something like that uh million
kilometers the average distance between
mars and the earth because that's the
one we would have to take into
consideration if we had to supply
the the mars the people that we put in
mars station if we put one in there well
it's about 225 million kilometers
away
we're closer to the sun
145 million kilometers
towards the sun and we're
80 million more kilometers than that
uh on the average uh to to mars
and this fell asks you know what's the
problem with supplying mars we do that
all the time with military outposts
is this guy kidding me or what i mean
you know the issue here is
we're going to spend gazillions of
dollars trillions of dollars
to
supply
a martian base
okay if we put people out there let's
assume we we put one out there you know
we put some people out there and usually
it takes anywhere from six months to two
years to get there according to our
current speeds okay let's concede that
we can go faster okay hopefully not at
the speed of light because einstein says
you turn into energy so hopefully you
don't do that okay we don't want to turn
into energy we just want to supply
energy
okay to the martians
uh
and so this guy says
what's the issue there i mean i don't
see anything we've supplied outposts in
the past why can't we supply people in
mars
well what can i say you know you got a
lot of investigating to do
yeah they're a little too far away to be
supplied continuously it's uh going to
cost us a lot of money to do so and uh
aside from that because
we can empty the global treasure chest
no problem
but uh yeah why would we put uh
some people on mars why would we put a
station on mars what's the point of
going to mars other than to say i got
here we made it and we developed this
technology that we can allows us to put
people on mars we have better space
suits we were able to construct a
station there by taking parts little by
little we were able to develop all the
technology necessary to put a station on
mars right let's pull out the champagne
bottles that's all celebrate
that's different than saying okay what
are we going to do now
what are we going to use that station
for are we going to plant potatoes out
there or carrots or whatever
are we really going to go out there and
do all this stuff
so
what can i tell you yeah now we're never
going to mars other than to
assuming we get there right but if we
ever get there it's just to put our feet
there and say we did it
that's the only perk just like we did
with the moon we went there we did it
we're back did a few experiments we're
done we're never going to the moon again
i mean no no purpose to go for going to
the moon that's why they haven't spent
any more money on those projects
going to the mars is just a goal like a
dream let's get there let's see if we
can do it let's see if we're smart
enough we can develop that technology
great once we do it we're done we only
do it once
and that's it
and then we scrap the project no need to
go to mars we're not going to evacuate
earth we're not going to um you know all
the people
we're we're not going to um colonize
mars the only purpose of mars is just a
little experiment lab experiment where
we say we did it that's it we were able
to do it once no more than that no no uh
vacation trips to mars like elon musk is
thinking
okay
okay moving on here let's move on to a
separate subject uh one is this a war
that's brewing in the east will there be
war well i say that uh whether there is
a war or not irrelevant i think the
united states has already won
that war
and it hadn't it had it didn't have to
shoot
a single bullet
and it may not even have to in the
future no matter what the russians do
they lose
and no matter what the russians do
well maybe not
whatever they do but germany is in big
trouble germany can lose big time
because this war is really against
germany if there is a war germany is in
trouble and so is the russia not the u.s
the u.s wins no matter what
either way
so uh
you know if russia advances over the
ukraine assuming they decide to do that
in the next couple weeks
um
well what happens is you have a war on
your hands uh they're gonna feed you the
ukrainians uh weapons to fight that war
uh maybe they can't
hold off the bear you know the bear just
takes over ukraine but all that uh they
did was essentially conquered territory
they used to have
okay on the other hand the united states
gains germany if that happens because
germany now has no
excuse
not to fall completely within
the uh
orbit of the united states so germany
right now has commerce with russia and
also has commerce with china and a lot
of that commerce affects the united
states affects the united states
interests and united states once it
stopped
among the things that they want stopped
is that uh
what is it that north stream pipeline
that goes from the uh russia the uffs
are you know the union of fewer and
fewer socialist republics because
they've lost all that white area between
germany and ukraine they lost poland
they lost slovenia they lost romania
bulgaria they lost all those countries
okay they lost a lot of countries that
used to belong
to the warsaw pact that was under the um
the um
uh
orbit of the of the soviet union and
when the soviet union uh turned into
russia in 1989 the whole thing began to
fall apart
uh all these uh
socialist republics and uh colonies they
suddenly became independent countries
and the only couple that are left are
belarus and ukraine okay so
you know uh the united states is not
losing anything without firing a shot
it's already won the war so united
states is not going to agree to any
conditions given by russia because it's
just smirking and saying do whatever you
have to we already won
okay so that's i think that's my five
cent's worth on what's going on there
okay and so um
one fellow says
says the following says
[Music]
says war is about power
not profits
because i said uh this is all about
profits and i got that from the movie
reds
when uh this fella john uh can't
remember his name but he was a real
fellow he was a
newsman
and he went to russia and he saw that
what was going on there in the
revolution 1917 he came back and he said
you know what's the world about profits
he said war is about power not profits
profits are also about power
okay um yeah there's way
to look at this i'm saying that the goal
is profits okay that's what people have
on their minds you know you have uh
powerful people right rich people who
they see expansion they see the empire
expanding it's always been like that you
know the empire expands
and you have
um
power but you have profits you know what
they're you know you have these uh
rich people they're not thinking of
power in the sense of military power or
like the politicians think uh you know
influence and so on what they want is
economics they're thinking about dollars
and these are people who push for some
of these wars because they're going to
make money
you know war
makes money for some people always
and so
in that sense it's about uh profits you
know people are thinking of how much
money am i going to make if there is a
war if if we can conquer more territory
if we have more influence in such and
such region and you don't have to really
have power in that sense
power in the sense military sense or in
the um
you know influence from one country on
another uh
that doesn't concern a rich person i
mean yeah it's indirectly it's there
but he's concerned about his money he
wants to make sure that he makes a
profit
and so i think the driving force the
underlying driving force is money the uh
military they're they're pawns
and yeah you can say it's about power
it's a like a circular arguments one
thing it leads to the other you know but
i think the driving force is
money you know i'll give you an example
you know uh chimps
um troops you know troops of chimps they
attract attack
other troops
and they go in there and they kill the
males especially the strong ones the
ones who can defend the troop
and they want the gals they're not
stupid
they want the chip gals the females okay
and that's why they go there they beat
them up beat the they kill them right
and they keep the gals you say well
that's about power yeah but the driving
force is not power they're not thinking
of oh i'm going to be powerful no
they're thinking about the gals
again they're not stupid
they want the gallows okay
so uh yeah you could say that the
driving force is the gals and power is
what they gain
because of their goal of their ideal
what they have been going through their
minds
okay uh
uh another subject similar okay your
opinion this pro-immigration policy
and pro-adoption of foreign children
this uh forcing into globalism the new
world order is due to your expected mass
extinction of humanity due to the loss
of genetic diversity and he puts a
little asterisk there and says uh bill's
theory is based on two consequential
steps
steps namely trade no more and loss of
human genetic diversity
and
no uh he's got it wrong my theory and i
don't know how else to put this forward
how people get it so wrong has nothing
at all nothing at all to do with loss of
genetic diversity with genetic diversity
at all okay
and uh
what it has to do with is something else
talking about the extinction of humanity
of man our species right we're saying
that uh
humans are gonna disappear because our
economic system
cannot grow forever
at some point it's gonna come to a stop
when it does not if it does but when
it does
then uh
profits will be no more right we have no
more profits we have no reason
and
in other words the whole system
collapses but what do i mean by collapse
i mean that money is no more trade
is no more okay you don't trade because
the currency we use is called money
something called money there are
different kinds of money out there okay
and you don't trade anymore you don't
exchange you don't have the currency you
don't exchange anymore
that's the issue and what happens when
you don't trade anymore when you don't
have exchange anymore when currency when
money is no more
okay
then
the companies that produce and
distribute food
to the masses
have no uh pecuniary reasons to continue
doing so so they don't produce food
they don't distribute food
and partly because they can't pay their
workers
to do the job because they have nothing
to pay them with because money is no
more
okay so the issue is money is no more
because the global economy cannot grow
forever it cannot grow forever in great
measure
because population does not expand
and that's because of the overturning of
the population pyramid but that's got
nothing to do with genetic diversity the
issue with genetic diversity has to do
with background extinction not with mass
extinction first of all second
humans will not die because of a
background extinction we will die in a
mass extinction we are the last of the
hominins of the hominins
how many knees whatever you want to call
them okay we are the last of our kind
okay we're the last dynasty
and you know we have no neanderthals no
florences no uh
homo erectus to mate with okay we're it
this is it we can only mate with each
other because we've been doing that for
200 to 300 000 years without mating with
the neanderthals either
we lost our genetic diversity that's the
situation today but that's got nothing
to do
with the mechanism of extinction of a
mass extinction of the extinction of
humans
so don't confuse the theories our our
extinction has nothing at all to do
with uh genetic diversity and here is uh
synthesis mass extinction many species
okay that's what
mass extinction is all about it's a uh
overturning of the ecological pyramid
and it's caused by overturning of the
population pyramid of plants
what is a mass extinction it's a uh
when a
food chain disappears completely that's
what it is another
uh food chain continues on without any
problem and what is a background
extinction that's where you can bring in
your
loss of genetic diversity but primarily
it's the overturning of the population
pyramid once the ecological pyramid the
other one is the population pyramid and
what is it it's caused by the extensive
inbreeding okay founder's effect
population bottlenecks
that's what causes the loss of genetic
diversity
okay so uh
let's get them right
background is not a
mass extinction they're two different
mechanisms okay
and just in case i put the skull and
bones there at the bottom that's
the yield secret society okay uh
people think that um all these
uh illuminati new world order people
skull and bones whoever that all these
people have control they will control us
and that they will uh you know have
underground tunnels and so on and so
that's my last point here let me show
that there here we have all these uh
rich people you know
buffets and gates and
uh elon musks and so on you know all
these people they're digging all these
cities underground you know they're
gonna hide there when the [ __ ] hits the
fan you know so
they're going to run down there as soon
as something happens
and i guess they're going to be pulling
the turnips from the bottom you know
carrots and stuff
radishes uh yeah so a fella says the
salary will be the food water uh air
health and safety of being there they
think that uh some people who work for
these fellas will go underground with
their families together with them and
that's gonna be their payment that's
what these people are suggesting another
fellow says the payment is a promise
that your family will get to survive
underground
why would gates
or musk or whoever
trust these workers if the only reason
these people work for them now is for
money
will they do it because they have faith
in them
is it about trust is it because they
love them
what's the reason
no uh
anyone who works for these people today
works for money
and if they built these cities down
there right everybody knows about them
because whoever built the city already
passed the word around said hey you know
gates is building a city underground in
south dakota
so we should all know about it all the
uh
reporters have already been there
underground they've seen it
you know uh you can't do something in
secret if you're gonna build something
like this a city underground someone's
got to know about it
and you're saying their families are
going to go down there why is gates
going to trust them why are these people
going to respect gates after
you know the whole world falls apart
above ground
so that's what you gotta tell me okay
you gotta tell me why anyone would uh
keep quiet
one issue
why anyone uh why anyone that goes down
there with his family would would
continue being faithful or subservient
to gates or mosque or whoever and why
gates or mosque or any of these rich
folk would trust these people to
protect them or do anything for them
once
the whole world is over above ground
uh food for thought that the ball is in
your court okay
okay let's move on here
took a lot of time there
let's uh move on to the review of what
we covered this month okay this is uh
strictly physics part okay and these are
the issues we had uh resistance and
resistor beginning of the month the
electron the proton the neutron and the
orbital essentially
everything involved with the atom okay
so here we have it um
uh this is where we start uh what these
people say uh quantum right is that
voltage
is some kind of power differential or
you know some potential difference
between one region and another
the problem is that they illustrate this
always as water flowing down you know
from a high point to a low point this is
the problem
and they say well that's how we
visualize voltage
well maybe this is the wrong analogy
because what they're saying essentially
is you know that we have an inclined
plane okay and so here's the incline
plane uh
uh
in fact in this case it's straight ahead
but they say you know somehow there's a
voltage differential and they see as a
potential
and i'm saying well okay but uh here
they're flat they're on a
horizontal surface why would the
electrons flow from one place to another
are we saying that if we reverse it and
say that you know maybe the negative
part is on the low side and the positive
side is like on a higher ground with the
electrons flowing the opposite direction
is this what these people are trying to
insinuate with their uh water flowing
down the hill
analogy okay so this is the the question
the question is whether this is a good
analogy for what we see you know with um
with uh electron flow is is this what
electron flow uh what electricity is and
of course if you get this run you're not
going to get resistance right okay
and here you have the electron flow okay
again are we saying that goes from high
to low we have all this
these negative and again the plus and
negative
uh are arbitrarily you can have also uh
holes moving in the opposite direction
for example right so the issue here is
you have um
all these electrons and somehow they're
flowing from high potential to low
potential is the water flow a good
analogy for what is happening there is
that what we're saying we're saying that
one atom is higher than the other one
are we saying that one um part of a
circuit is higher than the other one
because then you're talking about
gravity not about electricity okay are
they rolling downwards okay and
here you have again which i showed
you have all these little electrons
the little
soccer balls there that are moving from
one atom to another but then we have a
gap
okay not only
are are they moving faster i guess if
the
uh plane is more inclined than like on
the top where you have a low potential
right but then are these balls also
moving through the air are they moving
through the vacuum
can we have can we have
these electron balls move through the
vacuum
because
you know
either one of the two either electricity
is the flow of electron beams from atom
to atom
you know going from valence band to
valence band during the conduction band
there right moving from valence band to
valence band meaning the outer
part of the atom
or they move through a region that has
no atoms whatsoever
which is it
okay so this is this is the the problem
the problem is that resistance they're
saying like you know in the case of air
right air is a good resistor right uh
good insulator and what they say is that
you know the atoms the electrons for
some reason don't move through
uh the vacuum
do they or don't they do you need an
atom there for the electron to step on
for it to move to the other atom
or can the electron just you know is it
a little bead that can move through the
vacuum or through you know a place where
there are no atoms that's the issue
okay so this this is the question
okay
and so you know what is a resistor well
under our version here it is you see
what a resistor is
and we're saying that it's just a read
first of all you know electricity in
this under this version is uh the
rotations of merged electron uh shells
so we have all these atoms and they're
merged to each other really it's on the
molecular level but to simplify the
argument we say look imagine a bunch of
hydrogen atoms and they're all merged
uh
together because they're electron shells
or electron membranes are
fused into each other so think of it as
a long line of atoms okay
and that's what electricity is but what
is a resistor or some kind of insulator
well what it is is essentially that
you have atoms there but those atoms are
not moving as fast as where electricity
is
moving fast
and so what happens is you know you have
a region where the uh
all these
atoms or these molecules that are fused
with each other because of the type of
material could be glass could be air
could be you know some kind of insulator
rubber
they move slower in that region that's
all it is they're still connected but
they don't move as fast as in the other
place and depending on how fast it moves
it's a
you know a resistor with low um
impedance or high impedance it depends
on the speed with which it moves
okay so that's our version
okay we don't ask you to believe it we
ask you to understand it
okay moving on here give me a second
here
okay and then we have the electrons what
is an electron well here we have
a movie
of an electron movie a movie okay here
we have it this according to a swedish
university says they filmed an electron
and it's funny because you know the
electron they say it's a point particle
that is smaller a little bit smaller
than an atom
it's actually smaller than a proton
smaller than an atom and smaller than
anything we can see
with anything that we have today
in any of our technologies and these
people say they filmed and look they
made it quite big for us to see
and so the question is what did these
people film
because we can't see a hydrogen atom
hydrogen atom is think of a hydrogen
atom as a football field
the proton is like you know a dot or
like a football in the center of that
field that's how uh big a proton would
be
and the electron would be a little dot
in the stands you know maybe
[Music]
i don't know a little stone little stone
or maybe your cup of coffee
out there in the field it's a small
little piece of
a small
particle according to quantum mechanics
we can't see the atom we can't see the
football field much less can we see the
football in the center of the field
much less can we see the electron which
is
1800 times
less massive
meaning maybe smaller than the proton
and these guys filmed it
and not only did they film it you can
see that it's got
little lines there
in other words the this electron seems
to have um components to it something
smaller than that it's got parts to it
and today we say the the official
version is that there are no parts to
the electron the electron is known to
have no parts
and again because we can't see an
electron we can't see a proton we can't
see in a hydrogen atom
you know then how could these people
have filmed it
what does this have to do with reality
is this true what we're staring at or
are they giving you some
baloney are they feeding some baloney
okay so uh if those are the electrons
and these people are saying that these
electron beads can go from one galaxy to
the other
you know uh you can shoot them
and there have to be no atoms in between
i guess because if you shoot them strong
you know hard enough those electrons
will just go right through
space empty space vacuum nothingness and
reach the other galaxy
in fact uh keep in mind that these
electrons are st you know they're
discrete
balls each one of them okay think of
them as that
for a second
and um so these discrete balls that are
moving in one direction somehow
according to some dissident sites like
the electric universe produce these
filaments
you know they interconnect all galaxies
and all stars and everything out there
and you say how can that be
how could they be interconnected if the
electricity is flowing in a single
direction
and uh they're all um discrete little
balls you know so so how can this
possibly be
that
you know you have these filaments that
supposedly bind
uh all these uh galaxies and according
at least to the electric universe they
say that electricity is
gravity
okay so if it's gravity what they're
saying is that they're pulling
and how can you pull with all these
discrete particles
moving in a single direction and
and again being discrete
okay so uh we have a problem in several
aspects and one of them is again this is
the
famous electron bead it's a discrete
beat as you can see there it's made of
parts
and not only is it made of parts but it
is so small that people say that it has
no size whatsoever and yet
you have the people from the swedish
university one speech university lund i
think university uh
that filmed it
shake shake hands with it uh
they interviewed the electron yeah they
talked with it
okay so here's uh what quantum has
has uh this notion that the electron
beads are moving from one region to the
other
uh
apparently uh we need
these atoms for the electron b to go you
know from one atom to the next but
quantum mechanics has gotten rid of
you know the atoms itself they just do
it with electron beads
and uh here's uh again my notion of uh
their of their notion let me put it over
here
of uh what uh
electricity is
and what uh resistance is
okay and what it is is you have this the
serious problem where the electron beads
are moving through the vacuum
and they say it's a question of how
powerful your gun is
you got a big gun that's the notion
people have you know that then the
cannonball will go to the other side of
the of the to the other bank of the
river
that's the notion they have
and so they they think they don't need
the atoms sometimes they say they do
because when they explain electricity
they say
it's you know the conduction band what
is that well it means electrons are
moving from atom to atom that's the
first notion but then they get rid of
the atom and they say you know even if
you don't have an atom like if you have
total vacuum the little bead will go
right through the
vacuum if you have a powerful enough gun
so what's the powerful enough gun
it's the voltage
what is the voltage it's a potential
what is the potential well think of it
as water flowing down a hill
so you have gravity now is that what
electricity is well it's an analogy
you're not supposed to take it so
literally
so those are the answers you get okay
that's the establishment
okay
we moved on from there
let me get rid of this
okay and we went to protons and neutrons
well here we have the
an idea of what those are here we have
the proton and the neutron that's how
they're portrayed you have two ups and
one down and two downs and one up right
we're done okay
and this was a mathematical calculation
you know you had two thirds plus two
thirds in the case of the proton two ups
and
minus one third down and you got three
thirds which is one charge that's why
the protein has one charge that's why we
have three quarks in there okay that's
where you have two red ones there and
one blue one we're done okay and why
doesn't the neutron have any charge well
because the neutron has two downs and
one up and the two downs are two one
thirds negative one-thirds the up has
two-thirds and so you have two-thirds
minus two-thirds you have zero that's
why the neutron has no charge okay for
that they have to give the
quarks
partial or fractions
of
charge
meaning they have to have one third
charge in order for this to happen in
other words what you're talking about is
mathematical calculations it has
absolutely nothing to do with reality
out there they have not proven reality
what they've done if they said well this
is how we can justify charge on the
quark and on the proton and on the
neutron
okay
and then why don't these cars fly away
well for that they have to invent the
gluons and the gluons are portrayed as
springs so you see the springs there and
you say okay i understand that the
quarks don't fly away because they are
united they are bound by springs
turns out those are not springs those
are gluon particles twirling around
you know going inspire in a spiral
motion from one cl quark to another
because it's a particle the gluon is not
a spring at least you won't find it like
that in the standard model well if you
look up the gluon it's a little particle
that goes around
in a spiral motion from quart to quark
so how does that pull
two quarks together how does that
one-way
circular or spiraling or elliptical
motion you know helical motion how does
that pull on another quark
and what's more conspicuous here is if
we get rid of all those you know springs
and quarks the question is what is that
round sphere
that um
encapsulates the quarks and the gluons
what is that round sphere that we
identify with a proton and also with a
neutron in other words this is what i'm
talking about here here we are you'll
see it here
that's what we want to know what are
those spheres okay because here
you see the quarks and the gluons
okay
give me a second here
see here you see the quarks and the
gluons okay and you see that there's a
sphere there some
tenuous yellowish sphere that goes
around and prevents everything from
flying out okay so forget about the
gluons we don't even need them we can do
it with quarks the quarks can't leave
the uh the proton or the neutron why
because they're encapsulated within the
sphere they're trapped in that prison
okay and so this is what we want to find
out what are those spheres
they never they never identify those
they just put them by hand they say well
it is so
okay and so this is the problem we don't
know what those fears are
okay so the day they can identify those
fears maybe we can get started with the
presentation with their understanding
their theory okay right now we can't
understand their theory because we can't
understand why the quarks don't fly away
especially when the the gluons are just
a little spiraling particle that goes
from one quarter to the other how does
that pull two quarks together i mean if
i throw a stone on you how did i pull
you that's the issue okay i can pull you
with a spring we can all understand that
if you're tied to that other spring in
me here i can conceivably pull on the
spring and pull you over because this is
an elongated object that binds us both
but if i throw a stone to you and it
goes in a spiral motion to you how did i
pull you what's the mechanism
that's the question for that they had to
build a sphere around the proton and the
neutron they said now you understand
don't you now you see why the quartz
don't fly away they're trapped within
the sphere okay where's your sphere in
the standard model
has anybody identified the sphere and
given it a name say this is the sphere
this is the sphere that
you know encapsulates the proton and the
and the gluons
and they call those protons
it's a spherical proton
again by hand they've never seen a
proton can't see that that deep that far
okay
okay and uh that takes us to the orbital
again again and uh
one fell off oh hold on
let me get that out of the i got one in
between here
so here here's the orbital okay famous
orbital and the orbital should be like
the one on the right because they say
that the electron bead simply flies
around somewhere
around the proton okay in the case of
the hydrogen atom
and so what we should see is just a
little bead
next to a proton
uh bowling ball that's what we should
see and that's what you see on the right
now i put it in a circular orbit they
say that's not completely true the
electron can be anywhere fine but it's
always within a region close to the
proton it can't go beyond that a certain
region can't go within
the uh you know the distance uh
from the proton in other words the
electron never falls to the proton that
never the electron never leaves the
proton all by itself spontaneously
when you put two of these hydrogen atoms
together well that's what you should
have which you see on the right
instead you know when they put two atoms
together they illustrate something else
they illustrate this
encapsulating medium again unidentified
medium
they call it an energy level or they
call it an orbital okay and we don't
know what that orbital is what is an
orbital
is it uh some kind of um
you know substance
you know what is it is it a membrane is
is it some kind of uh wrapping that we
put around atoms
see they change their physical
interpretation
that's the issue the issue is that they
should be illustrating what you see on
the right and that's not what they
usually illustrate they use usually
illustrate what you see on the left and
they never
justify how these regions merge
you know it would be much simpler to say
that those regions are actual membranes
of some kind some kind of material right
then we can make sense of that but as
long as they call them orbitals and they
say well an orbital is just a concept
mathematical concept then we cannot
understand that we cannot understand
their physical interpretation of how two
hydrogen atoms merge
to form you know a hydrogen gas molecule
and that's what the whole issue is about
okay so yeah we we don't know what uh
resistance is because resistance they
say it's just a material that you put in
there that causes electricity
to go slower or not at all
you know the more resistance it is the
more resistive it is
the more it becomes
an insulator
great
what is that based on that's based on
two concepts one the potential
between uh you know the voltage
supposedly potential which they
illustrate as water running down a hill
which is the incorrect analogy because
that's got to do with gravity not with
electricity and that's easily proven you
know if you want to proof
uh if you want you know an argument
that's really valid all you have to do
is raise the other terminal up and find
out if the electrons from the other way
they don't
okay
so uh
it's based on that notion wrong
notion of voltage it's the
irrational notion also of electricity
because they never identify whether
electricity is the flow of electron
beads from atom to atom right or is it
can the electron beat go through empty
space
and that's just one of the issues
another of the issues is you know what
compels each bead to move in the first
place why would a why would a bead
move from one atom to the next what
pushes it what pulls it
you got to have a mechanism for that you
can't just say well you know the energy
compelled it to move what does that mean
energy is a concept you can't say that
energy is a baseball pad and it hit the
ball you can't do that that infinity
okay and and then you have you know uh
the proton and the neutron you know
they're encapsulated within this
mystical
ball
sphere
membrane i don't know what it is
they never identified it they just call
it a proton and a neutron
and uh you know and then uh
again they have all these gluon springs
holding the protons
within that ball together and it's not a
spring it's
you know a
one-way particle that is
uh has helical motion
you know from one
part to another we don't know how that
pulled two parts together
so that cannot be understood the
electron bead is made into this monster
that can flow you they even filmed it
and it turns out you know you can't
photograph
a hydrogen atom no one can tell you what
a hydrogen atom is but they know what an
electron is they filmed it and
interviewed it and you know uh shook
hands with it
great you know i mean
what are they selling you
uh
okay
anyways let's go with some of the
questions people ask and then we'll move
on to the questions people ask today
okay here's goes the first one fellow
says according to the rope hypothesis
the neutron is a set of ropes of
different atoms that come together in a
certain location forming an
agglomeration of the size and weight of
a hydrogen atom
conclusions and the deductions the
neutron is an object external to the
atom
no
now you got it wrong i said clearly
clearly free
neutron okay free you don't have to pay
for it okay it's free free neutrons are
neutrons which are outside the atom
there are neutrons out there which
spontaneously every 50 10 to 15 minutes
i got different numbers out there from
these people but
uh they go through these uh beta decays
uh processes where a neutron converts to
an atom hydrogen atom and a hydrogen
atom converts to a neutron spontaneously
one turns into the other
every 15 or so minutes three neutrons
then you have neutrons which are inside
atoms nucleus of the atoms okay
and those neutrons you know form the
different elements okay so
important
free that word free okay keep that in
mind free neutron and a neutral is
formed with a fixed number of strings in
order to reach the size and weight of a
hydrogen atom the neutron weighs almost
as much
as an atom they both weigh almost the
same thing okay because all the ropes in
the universe converts upon one and the
other
that's why neutrons and hydrogen atoms
have approximately the same weight
not as weight
hey
some people call it mass
they don't know any better
okay
give me a second here
get rid of this one
okay another fella says
says thing in italian i think the same
guy in italian is translated as kosa
okay same in spanish cosa
they have the same meaning kosa okay got
it
uh with which we refer in a generic way
to everything that exists
yeah that's the problem people have
thought throughout the last ten thousand
years that the word thing
is the same thing as exist
they think that these two words are
synonyms and if and i did mention in the
past that uh both
david hume
so-called philosopher and another
so-called philosopher uh emmanuel kant
can't
uh these two guys said the same thing
they said they couldn't tell the
difference between that which exists and
an object they thought they were they
were synonyms and that was the problem
the problem is they never distinguished
between
the word object
thing entity
and the word exist
they always confuse those they thought
it was they were synonyms because they
were always thinking of see and touch
they say an object that which you can
see and touch exists that which you can
see and touch
that's the problem
and neither of those words are defined
as c touch in physics
an object is that which has shape and
exists is that which in addition to
shape it has to have location otherwise
it doesn't exist there are objects that
do not exist there are objects you can't
see or
see and there are objects you can't
touch you certainly can't touch that
table that the clean cotton has on the
other side of the universe and so yeah
he says exists here has a generic
meaning and not in the strict sense that
bill defines yeah that's the problem
that's exactly the problem that they
never no one has ever been able to find
the word object and the word exist more
important yet they were never able to
realize how important those two words
are bestie for science specifically for
physics
okay and uh another
problem follows us
no more new inventions since the
computer the 3d printer
that's all i could think about such an
invention would not create and not
create more not only i guess
such an invention would not create more
jobs in manufacturing oh it would not
create jobs in manufacturing but this
invention will increase the diversity of
products people will want and will
create more service jobs
yeah and the work
the issue was manufacturing jobs that's
the first issue we need to
clarify okay people do not have
everything they want people want more
life more health more time yeah
people
want those things because they already
have all the material
things that's the answer we already have
the refrigerator we already have the
stove we have a bed we have
uh you know utensils plates cups
uh what do you need every day couch
for couch potatoes tv set maybe maybe
radio maybe tv maybe uh you know a
computer maybe a phone
we have all the material things we have
that's why the only thing you can think
about
is services abstractions entertainment
you know
nonsense
not not real stuff abstractions
okay so uh this fellow continues as if
human organs can be manufactured by 3d
printers using the specific dna of this
client in other words this guy is saying
we can use these 3d printers to do some
by bio stuff
and right now there's not even a hint of
that all they can do with this is use
plastic metal and
what is it resin and so on okay
cloning animals both living in extinct
will create a demand for more cloners
just think about what this guy is saying
veterinarians and zoos around the globe
with exotic animal yeah it turns out
we're trying to get rid of the zoos
because people don't like to see uh
animals in a zoo you know they think
they're trapped or it's unnatural or in
circuses for that matter an artificial
womb you couldn't fathom who would want
such a thing use you you're so old
school bill
many men and would welcome the expansion
of women's reproductive rights the
option of having children without the
risk of surrogate mother
being granted paranormal rights by a
court of law i mean all the reasoning
this guy put in this okay he must have
burned his brain a man can lose his wife
children home and much money and divorce
as artificial womb would also create
demand for more service jobs nannies
tutors caretakers
oh my god poor fellow
he thinks we're we're going to use 3d
printers
[Music]
to
flood the world
and i looked up you know how many i
should have put that in there how many
printers they sold in the world
well they're in the thousands and by the
year what was it
2030 or thereabouts
they plan to sell a few million
nobody needs a 3d printer no one on the
planet earth okay
uh we don't use 3d printers like we use
a telephone we don't use 3d printers
like we use the car
everybody wants a car
nobody wants a 3d printer because the 3d
printer what does it do it makes you a
cup of plastic plastic cup okay so i
made a plastic cup or maybe a metal cup
i don't know okay so you got the cup
oh so interesting so nice oh i made a
cup
great and
i mean you could go down the store and
buy the cup you don't need to buy the 3d
printer other than entertainment
3d primer is just entertainment other
than
in manufacturing
there are companies who bring 3d
printers and they produce maybe a i
don't know a nail or a screw or some
little gadget that they can produce
easily maybe with a 3d printer or maybe
something made out of plastic maybe a
plastic uh bulk
okay for example
and
what it does is replace the human we
don't need the human because we have the
3d printer to do all this and maybe we
have one guy manning 10 3d printers
maybe even computerized from from afar
maybe a hundred of them you know and
a long line of 3d printers we produce
anything we want all we did was get rid
of people from manufacturing
to produce stuff
that now people can buy in the store
because they don't need to buy the 3d
printer to do the same thing which costs
a lot more
and yeah nobody has a 3d printer because
no one needs no one when they invented
3d printers the whole world didn't go
out there so i need a pre 3d printer
okay we don't need 3d printers okay we
don't need them at all it's not an
invention
all it is is a tool
that helps you do something uh more
automatically that we already used to do
so it's an innovation in that sense it's
an innovation all you did is replace
humans with with a robot
is a robot an invention yeah you could
say it's an invention
that doesn't help manufacturing it's not
like everybody wants a robot in his
house to do what a robot does in a uh in
a manufacturing capacity you know you
have all these arms that help in the for
example in the auto industry we don't
need one of those robots on home and say
okay do this or do make the auto phone
make the car for me
we don't do that it's not going to
happen ever okay we're going to buy the
car from chrysler from 4 from mitsubishi
we're not gonna
we're not gonna bring a robot home to
build a car for us
3d printer or or whatever
and yeah another fellow along the same
lines he says totally new inventions in
the last decade
is this augmented reality artificial
intelligence whoa
artificial intelligence i guess that's
what he's got artificial intelligence
internet of things 3d printing or comp
also everybody goes to 3d printing they
think it's a big invention yeah computer
vision touch screen uh and infinity
display crowdfunding uh crowd funding
websites cloud computing oh man all
these inventions that we had yeah and
again uh i made the distinction between
inventions and innovation
and as far obviously he hasn't caught on
he doesn't understand that okay so here
it is okay let's put them side by side
okay so what's augmented reality that's
known as drugs
ai that's a robot okay
uh it comes from the russian word robot
means uh to work
3d printer uh
gutenberg invented in 1450 or
thereabouts uh so we already had
printers okay
no need to bring new printers in in fact
even before gutenberg they they printed
letters in the days of the pharaohs uh
they're known as hieroglyphics look it
up yeah you'll find out yeah we had
printers for a long time we also have uh
photocopiers okay and they do quite a
bit of printing for us
computer vision more that's just more ai
more artificial intelligence what is it
a field of artificial intelligence that
trains computers to
interpret and understand the visual
world
uh infinity display that's just a large
screen and curved sides that's all it is
what's crowd funding sites well that's
services what's cloud computing more
services on demand computing
it's delivering hosted services over the
internet so although none of these are
inventions okay so let's find out what
an invention is let me show you what i'm
looking for when i'm saying inventions
because people don't understand what the
word invention means they they get
confused with so much abstraction that
we have today that they think oh we have
so much so many inventions to invent
in front of us as soon as we hit that
singularity the technological
singularity oh man those robots those
computers they'll be inventing new stuff
forever and ever unimaginable it'll just
take off exponentially
and it turns out we have everything we
need
we have absolutely everything we need
that's why all we can think about today
is entertainment anything related to
entertainment internet etc that's all
just entertainment that's just to pass
the time
so let me talk about ex uh inventions
and the these are off the top of my head
okay okay
just things that came out i'm sure
you're gonna find a million more and
you're gonna say you missed this one
yeah i'm just a whole bunch okay but
here it is the fire
now that was an invention okay or maybe
we discovered it could be a discovery in
which case it's not an invention we just
saw a forest fire put the little branch
in there and started using fire okay we
invented the stove because of that you
know we had a forest
a fire a place or some fire where we uh
cooked food maybe a campfire or
something okay so that's the stove we
invented the stove and we cook food
uh we invented the bed
now everybody needs a bed everybody in
the world invented beds okay uh seat you
know you had to put your butt on
something okay a table yeah you ate
maybe on something or maybe cut
something on a table or whatever okay
spear knives all kinds of tools you know
hammers hatchets
okay
plates
you know at some point we invented the
plate we had to put you know we stopped
eating you know directly
the uh lamb chop directly we put it on a
plate you know we invented utensils and
so on you know cups
okay and at some point we invented the
wheel
we found that was easier to
roll things okay than to carry them you
know or drag them or whatever okay the
printer you know at some point we
invented a printer uh oh
it's guttenberg was the first guy in the
west it was all the printer already
existed in china okay
clocks
um
yeah we invented the clock the watches
the pendulum one clock first and so on
and that was a big invention everybody
wanted one eventually everybody's got
one i mean
except me i don't use watches i don't
use telephones okay but uh because i'm
old school
so i don't have those things uh but uh
clocks yeah just about everybody's got a
watch around his wrist
okay
and uh so those are things that those
are inventions people
buy by the millions uh
engine you know we had all kinds of
steam engine first then we have the
combustion engine so on okay and we
eventually put that in a car made it run
put it on an airplane minute run
telephone big invention put a lot of
people to work everybody's got a phone
in the world except me you know
i don't use
tv sets i don't use tv either you know i
just have computers so i don't have tv i
used to have tvs so but a lot of people
have tv still in the world and they're
being replaced by
the phone which has a tv
phone
and
computer all in one portable so it's not
an invention it's just an agglomeration
of several inventions put into one which
people wanted you know for a long time
now they got an all-in-one kind of thing
uh deal it's not really a new invention
it's like you know it's a way of putting
several inventions together existing
inventions together that's all it was so
it's a new way of doing something uh
the washing machine we invented the
washing machine the refrigerator we
invented all these things that everybody
wants one everybody pretty much has one
that has a house or an apartment right
uh
a lot of people are getting rid of them
because they do their washing outside
etc but everybody needs this stuff
everybody needs to wash clothes uh some
people are so rich that they buy clothes
every day see they don't wash them great
okay uh
and then uh the chip the computer yeah
obviously that was a revolution those
are known as inventions okay they're
solid things they're
you know you can put your hand on that
okay you can touch it
it's got to be in a gadget
okay for it to be an invention and
hopefully everybody wants one if not
it's not much of an invention i mean pet
rock was that an invention well you can
say it's an invention yeah i mean
what is a pet rock is that an invention
it's just something that made someone
money for a given period of time i think
he made like thirty five thousand
dollars selling these pet rocks because
it was a new idea great is that an
invention
no
that's not an invention okay it's
something that made someone money for a
little while for a small
portion of the population
you know invention is something that
everybody out there needs
and it's got to be a gadget and we
already have all those gadgets that we
need
i don't know give me a gadget
that everybody in the world wants a
gadget not a service okay and one that
doesn't exist okay and don't put three
or four of them together and don't tell
me that well they don't want blue cars
they want red cars yeah a red car is the
same thing as a blue car okay
the fact that you painted it red does
not make it a new invention
and a lot of people think of all these
cosmetic changes and they say oh we have
a new invention
no no
what can i say
anyways let's get down to the questions
people asked today let's see if i can
see some give me a second here let me
read them
read a couple here
can't go through all of them too many
okay the stephen crothers understand the
rope hypothesis i don't know ask him
yeah uh
does dave morgan core understand the
rogue hypothesis dave morgan
dave morgan doesn't even know what an
object is
we had a long debate with uh months
worth of debate with dave morgan poor
guy he he teaches um mathematics to his
students out there what is in virginia
somewhere
okay um
uh
okay thanks for the audio video good i
just found that out okay
again
scientific math and peer review are
important to make a correct theory no
such thing as a correct theory
there's only rational theories and
irrational ones are not part of science
and correct is your opinion some people
you know when you believe in a theory
you say that theory is correct
correct
for you okay so no no such thing as a
correct theory theory is just a
theory is an explanation in case of
physics of a mechanism
uh
some people believe in this mechanism
other people believe in this other
mechanism okay and so
everybody chooses sides they vote
and that part is religion the important
part that concerns science is the
objective mechanism that you understand
it so we have a mechanism this guy says
this is how a car works
or how an airplane works or how a ship
works i don't know and so he's got a
theory of how this thing works
okay and some people say i don't think
that's the way it works i think it works
through angels spirits get into the
machinery there and move all these
things around okay so this is what he
believes
this is how what this fellow believes
this other guy believes in something
else
but the mechanism
is objective
and that's what concerns science science
had better be universal
in the sense that you have an objective
mechanism everybody watches it everybody
understands the same thing from what
they watched everyone can if you ask
each one what did you see well this is
what i saw
okay so everybody should be able to
describe the same thing they saw the you
know the same explanation the same
mechanism
now this guy says there's three or four
of these theories out there three or
four
explanations one guy believes and this
one the other guy and that one fine
that's their belief they're now you're
talking about religion what people
believe their opinions that doesn't
concern science
math is magic yeah
okay
i'm not saying someone said who are you
to say space time is wrong i'm not
saying space time is wrong i'm saying
space time is irrational
let's get the words correct okay
okay so
space time is not wrong i'm saying it
one more time if i say wrong in the past
uh
it was a slip of the tongue okay let me
state it clearly space-time is
irrational it's irrational first because
it's four-dimensional no such monster in
science in physics
second because it's a concept and these
people are saying that this concept this
abstract concept time
is worked they're saying the seconds are
warped that's what they're saying that's
the mechanism of gravity that's why the
earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system because time is warped because
the skin of earth like the little ball
on the roulette comes against a wall a
curved wall of time
and that's why the earth doesn't fly out
of the solar system in fact uh
brian green famous uh mathematician
he illustrates it and and reaffirms that
that's what it is
it's not like i'm inventing this you can
watch um what is it fabric of the cosmos
by brian greene
and i'm not sure which one it's either
the first or the second one and one
talks about space the other
time
you'll find it there you'll see that he
illustrates
the uh
warping of space time
and the earth rolling around
curved time so it's not like i invented
this okay yeah that's why
space time is irrational no such
physical object and that's what they do
with space time they treat it as a
physical object to get their
gravity uh mechanism across to the
public
and then they tell you at the end well
by the way don't take the analogy too
literally yeah sure
okay uh see
[Music]
energy is wrong yeah peer reviewers uh
pass it along as fast yeah correct uh
that's the problem energy is not a
physical object there's no physical
standalone object called energy and i
challenge anyone in on planet earth okay
unless you're from another planet to
bring energy and put it on the table
show or or or a mock-up
you don't have to bring the real thing
not necessary but bring me a mock-up
of energy what you think it looks like
bring it here put it on the table i want
to see it i want to touch it
for those who believe in see and touch
i want to see and touch energy and the
only way i can do that is if you can
bring it to the conference
and put it there in the middle of the
room so that everybody can see and touch
energy
and again it doesn't have to be the real
thing the invisible stuff out there
floating no problem
bring the bring a mock-up show me what
it looks like that way we can all see
and touch energy and say okay i see what
energy looks like according to your
brain according to how you are
visualizing this thing
it's the only way to do it okay
otherwise you can't talk about energy
being a saint a thing if it's not a
thing you cannot say that energy did
this and energy did that energy could
not have pushed the electron from one
energy level to another from one orbital
to another because there is no such
thing as energy to do the pushing or
pulling okay so that's the problem okay
let's get it right you can't use energy
and physics in science until you
as an object unless you come in and put
it inside in in the middle of the room
or the conference room and say here it
is this is what it looks like touch it
see it okay now we see it and touch it
see i can do that with a rope
i don't have to bring the real
electromagnetic rope i bring the rope i
bring this rope and i say this is what
light looks like
okay and you can see it you can touch it
there you see it touch it
this is the shape
of what light looks like according to me
this is what i'm proposing this is my
assumption
do the same thing with energy okay
bring energy and say this is what energy
looks like
i mean i don't care if that's the real
energy the one mother nature uses out
there i don't care about that i care
about you presenting it so that we know
what's inside your mind it's like the
guy with god he says i believe in god
okay no problem bring god and put him in
front of me so that i can see and touch
what you have going through your mind i
want to know what your god looks like
what is he going to bring a bearded guy
and put him in front says okay if that's
what god looks like okay that's his god
no problem do that with energy bring me
energy i want energy
okay
okay
give me a second here i'm just reading
along the line going fast as
fast as i can here
i moon you all yeah
the moonies
okay helium okay
does the moon orbit around the earth yes
according to the word orbit it means
going around
revolution
so if that's the definition of the word
orbit the moon orbits the earth it just
goes around the earth whether it spins
on its axis or not is a separate issue
you know but uh
when when you have this situation again
it's a question of semantics it's a
question of uh
you know what we mean by orbit that's
all it is and i'm saying orbit is this
you know uh the the uh ball going around
my finger the ball is orbiting my finger
that's that's what we call orbit now if
you've got a different definition okay
then uh you got to proceed with your
definition we need to know what the word
orbit means to you for me orbit means
one
celestial object going around another i
don't care if it's spinning or not
irrelevant
just one object going around another
that's orbit period we're done
okay so yeah does the moon orbit the
earth yes it does it goes around the
earth
more or less in a circular pattern
slightly elliptical
and does it spin no what the spit means
spin means what you see with the top
that's called spinning
and the moon doesn't do that the moon
always shows the same face towards the
earth meaning again
if it's synchronous it's because
the moon is attached somehow to the
earth why would it why would it go
constantly around the earth if it's not
physically attached to the earth
and you say well i can't see or touch
what's in between of course you can't
okay because you're talking about very
thin very
uh small
you know
uh mediators that connect two atoms
which we can't see so obviously if these
ropes which i call the electromagnetic
rope binds two atoms
okay if it binds two atoms and we can't
see an atom you can imagine how thin
the ropes are
burrows are much thinner much smaller
than an atom which we can't see
we can only see many atoms like a table
that's called many atoms okay so we can
see a table but we can't see each
individual atom that forms the table so
you can imagine how thin how small the
ropes that connect each one of these
atoms
is
okay so the whole universe according to
our theory or assumption really is uh
is that it's uh
crisscrossed by
countless
uh magnetic uh
ropes
okay
give me a second here
well sir do you believe all shapes are
objects it's a definition of object
object
that which has shape
it's the other way around it's not the
you got to define the word object we're
interested in the word object because
you can't do physics without objects
okay what are you going to do it with
nothing
no hopefully you do physics with objects
with things
with entities and we say all these words
are synonyms because it's either object
or age either it has shape or it doesn't
if it doesn't it's a concept
if a word represents
that which doesn't have shape we're
talking about a concept such as nothing
nothing is a concept on the other hand
uh an object is that which has shape
so anything that has shape is an object
it doesn't matter if it's 2d or 3d
3d objects not all of them exist
you have ideal 3d objects okay
imaginary objects and superman is a 3d
object that we can imagine we can even
turn them into a real thing in front of
us you know make a little dummy there
and say that's superman 3d okay but
you know you have superman in your head
you imagine him as a 3d object different
than you imagine a circle which is a 2d
object and neither superman nor the
circle exist so existence has nothing to
do with the object in other words
they're not synonyms okay and object 3d
out here okay and that one is one that
exists okay so existence
an object that exists has to have shape
and it has to have location with respect
to the other objects
2d objects they have shape they have
form
and shape and form are synonyms in
physics there's no difference between
those two words okay so whether it has
shape or form people say 2d 3d
shape period we're done
shape form synonyms if it has shape it
has form and it's it's an object you
have something there and if it doesn't
have shape the word represents a concept
energy force mass
field time all those are concepts
okay so you can't imagine the
shape of field what is a what is the
field what is the
shape of a field can you bring a a field
without the magnet it's got to be a
standalone object obviously right
we don't need an extra object
we don't need to have it be a dependent
object it's got to be completely
independent okay
and again i give the example of a ring
or a plate that is on the head of an
angel we don't call it a ring we don't
call it a play we don't call it a cloud
we call it a uh halo
because a halo has some connotations
it's holy okay
halo is holy and the only way you can
get it to be holy is with the angel you
remove the angel it's no longer a halo
because it's not holy all you have is a
ring or a plate or a cloud
or that
i was think what is
okay so yeah uh let me continue here see
what else we have
uh
morris has been predicting the last
generation for a generation
yeah that's true uh because i don't
predict it's not a prediction you're
focusing on the wrong issue again it's
not that we're we're predicting anything
we're giving you a mechanism we're
saying look the mechanism that's going
to kill man is this why is it this
because that's what happened in the past
to all other mass extinctions
and we extrapolate that onto man and man
it turns out cannot escape that same
mechanism
so it's a mechanism so when people talk
about prediction and the fact that he's
saying oh he's predicting the future
you're focusing on the wrong issue the
issue in science we're concerned about
mechanism especially in physics so
you got to focus on the mechanism not
not
when it's gonna happen but people focus
on that because people for the most part
are religious people they're
spiritualists they're not materialists
materialists are people who are
concerned are rationalists first because
they understand that the universe is
just atoms
as mr democritus said once and not only
are they adam but that's what's real
and all the other stuff is you know in
the heads of people uh spiritualist they
they think that
the
abstractions out there are more
important than the matter
and mother nature she doesn't know about
abstractions god he doesn't know about
distraction the devil father universe
they don't know about
abstraction all they know is about atoms
that they understand that's the universe
out there that's nature but what you're
thinking in your head
doesn't concern them you know they can't
see that they don't manipulate that
okay uh let's keep going here
well it says there's more recent and
highest resolution of the electron now
uh hopefully
we don't even have a resolution for the
one in the past no resolution whatsoever
they've never never been able to see an
electron
and you don't have to take my word for
it okay by the way go to the wikipedia
or any other source wikipedia is a good
source for this but you can go anywhere
else and they'll tell you the electron
is a point particle
what does that mean
uh point particle it means an elementary
particle meaning it's
it's not made of any smaller parts why
is it not made of smaller parts because
they can't see that far that's what they
tell you they say that there's no way
they can tell
with the technology we have today okay
how big an electron is and whether it's
made out of smaller parts because
they've reached the end of technology at
that point
so if they can't see an electron much
less can they fill that electron show it
to you this big show with internal parts
all these lines that are inside it
what have they found
okay and so yeah again
you got a contradiction there you gotta
you gotta you don't gotta you don't have
to bring it against me you gotta take it
against the people who say it's a point
particle that it has no size that
they've never seen one because they've
never seen a proton which they've never
seen a a hydrogen atom
and the highest resolution they've ever
been able to see is what i showed the
other day which is uh
uh
i can't remember what metal it was and
they seen this atom which is like what
is it uh
141 i think it was 141 nucleons
and they can barely see it from a bird's
eye perspective as a little ball out
there in the distance and that's the
best resolution we have of an atom
they claim and that was what june of 21
2021
so they have the contradiction not me
they have to resolve the contradiction
how can they on the one hand say that
this atom which has 141 nucleons protons
and neutrons right
uh
50 or so electrons buzzing around forget
about those those are too small no
problem but all these nucleons and they
see it as a ball in the distance like a
little like you would see a tennis ball
at a mile away that's how they
filmed or they photographed this atom
and these people are saying they
filmed
an electron bead moving around and it's
got all these parts in it
yeah sure they've got a contradiction
not me okay so don't bring it up against
me you're beating up on the wrong guy
i'm just using their information
okay
uh let's see what else we got here
i said we can weigh electricity
yeah
we try to weigh love also you know
there's uh you can there's a love
weigher out there you can buy it a new
invention
they weigh electricity electricity is a
concept in fact it's a dynamic concept
you you can perhaps say that you can
weigh an electron maybe a proton maybe
an atom but to weigh electricity which
is the motion of electrons i don't know
how you can weigh motion you know it's
very tough
does nonsense have mass right he said it
correctly does nonsense have mass how
much does nonsense weigh
okay
okay folks well i'll leave it at that
and uh we'll see you next